and have a vote and have a not point that I want to make. Shut
up, bro. Stop talking about this. Stop. Dude, >> wait.
Wait. I gota be I got to be both with you because this is what
was going to happen. You're talking about each other. Hutch.
Your analogy of the thing of like they're not helping build the
wall, right? Hud. Please h I want you to listen to me. Please.
Hutch. The idea that tell me something is wrong with me and Overwood
Boy. Is that [laughter] >> Oh, no. Ogre boy just laughed
at him.
>> The wall, RIGHT? WAIT, WHAT? >> NO WAY. NO WAY.
OGRE BOY IS TAUNTING HIM. WHAT? >> And then they didn't
build it out of concrete and then the ocean destroyed the village
or whatever, right? Like can you engage with like they think
this is the only thing that would have won the the election.
I don't >> dude Ogre boy won so hard. Oh my god. Add him
to live and learn right now. Add Ogre Boy to live and learn.
This show goes up 500 concurrent viewers every single week. Add
him now. Add him now.
He's getting heated on live [music] and learn now. Why don't
we take a look? Me look at Hutch's POV and live and learn. Let's
see what's going on.
>> because [laughter]
there
it so her now obviously this mirrors exchanges that are had all
the time between tons of people like ourselves in all sorts of
ways. So I'm hoping a productive conversation could be had with
all of that as a springboard >> and there you go. >> If
I can oftentimes in uh online politics people will craft analogies.
Let me try to craft an analogy here. Say that you have, you know,
a village of people. It's 2,000 people. The number doesn't matter.
And they have some kind of a barricade around the village that
they live in. And the barricade is somehow threatened by something.
Let's say like water, you know, like let's say like the the the
the oceans rise, right? And and it's established that the people
that live in this village, they have to reinforce that wall,
otherwise the ocean's going to come in and just like uh drown
everybody and destroy the village. And let's say you have somebody
that's in that village talking a lot about the threat of >> why
why does Soy pill look like he's basically been chatting with
like a 15-year-old on some app. Okay. And he's waiting in a hotel
room for them to show
Why are you wearing sunglasses inside right now? There's no light
in that room. That room doesn't even HAVE A PRIMARY LIGHT. WHY
DO YOU HAVE SUNGLASSES ON? What the [__] is
>> The ocean and the water and all that. It's just like
this is really bad. there's water coming. But then let's say
that person doesn't help reinforce the wall and then the wall
collapses.
Would do you think that the person who didn't help potentially?
Uh or not potentially. Do you think that the person who didn't
help could have helped to like stop the water coming in everybody?
>> Ogre, you want to take that? >> No, no, no. I
asked you. >> Um I'd like to to to go over to Ogre because
I I just >> Can I actually
Wait, wait. I can already talking past each other and and and
what's going to happen is >> tell me if this is wrong.
The demon bug. This is my position, but tell me if this is a
good steelman of what you guys are saying. The people that were
holding out for concessions were not thinking that with their
help, they would have stopped Trump. Their thought is, if you
don't listen to me and concede to my argument on Gaza, you will
lose. So, it would be
to be more specific, if you don't do the thing that I want you
to do, I will help Donald Trump win.
>> I understand the
not helping.
They are already trying to do something about an apathy that
is that that is going to be there whether you like it or not.
I very much like ogre because I know ogre boy has a lot to say
about this and I said a mouthful and >> you're fine placed.
We're we're going to be fine. We're going to be fine covering
hunch right now. >> Talk very capably about
I thought you changed your mind about like voting for Kamla and
you think that that would have been the right thing to do. Didn't
you tell me that? >> The discussion in the moment is still
the same. The idea of what a lot of people were trying to do
in 2024.
Wait, every everybody has Okay, there's like very it's very easy
to understand what the opinions would be, right? Like
the opinions are just along the lines of like, okay, the best
thing to do is to threaten to withhold your vote to negotiate
to say, "Hey, we're like a block. We're going to vote as a block.
You should respect us."
If you will never ever withhold your vote, if there is no way
you will ever withhold your vote, you have no negotiating power,
right? just like there are a whole bunch of other blocks that
that demand respect, right?
It it just it makes sense to do that. But I think almost everybody
who was in the um in even the uncommitted camp, I think a lot
of those people have still voted
I really I think it's been super overblown how many people decided
to vote against Kamla or abstain from voting based on Israel
Palestine. I think it's been I think both sides overblow it a
lot basically just because one it on the left like they overblow
it because it gives them it makes it appear they have more power.
They have like more people they can command to vote and on the
and I guess sorry in I the progressive side and then the more
liberal block overblows it because they want to blame the left.
It's very funny. It was akin to yelling at the main character
inside the movie theater while you're watching a horror movie
trying to tell somebody that the murder >> this was a United
>> the entire city of Mi oh an entire city in Dearbornne
Dearborn might have been the the case but I don't think the margin
I think we looked it up I think the margin in Michigan
even if you flip Michigan does Trump still win Trump still wins
right even if you flip Michigan
like I think I understand where that comes from but it's not
like Michigan is the only argument you have even close and even
if you flip Michigan you lose >> state's representative
who has a tremendous amount of influence in the state that she
serves which happened to be a battleground state and she could
have at any point told her uh supporters in no uncertain terms
the threat of Donald Trump is real he is going to probably be
worse than the first term he everything that they're threatening
to do in project 2025 sounds like it will do a lot of damage
it will kill a lot of people we can get into the USA ID cuts
But feel like that point has been made a thousand times. And
nobody forced her. You say holding out for concessions. I don't
know what that means. Like through the election. What does that
even mean? >> What do you mean you don't know what that
means? >> What does it mean to hold out? She was looking
for a concession the day before the election. Was she hoping
for a concession on the day of the election? >> For her
to to to either do uh a weapons embargo or to
her to promise a ceasefire hopefully. And that didn't happen.
But
that was if if she if she had done that >> 10 million people
are going to die from US ID cuts and it's partly her fault. It's
partly her fault. Yes.
>> Veim what he's asking is yes. Holding out for a concession
is a valid he understands the concept of hey I I don't really
want to endorse until you do this. But once it becomes clear
this is not going to happen 24 hours before because she's not
going to pass that in 24 hours. Why not at that point then >> Because
it's a
genocide. >> Is Donald Trump a is he a fascist? >> What's
that? Is Donald Trump a fascist? >> Donald Trump is a fascist
and that's why
>> as I said
>> Kla still won the county Dearbornne is in by 29%.
>> Well would the mar I mean would the margins have run
up I guess is the
>> throughout the throughout her campaigning spoke to that
constantly
>> You're not you're not you seem to be just breezing past
the responsibility that people have to use their influence. They
use their influence to effect the best possible outcome. Okay.
If >> now did people bring up the tweet with Hutch where
he basically said, "We don't need you. You
>> did. Did Did people bring this up? I hope this tweet
has been brought up. This tweet needed to have been brought up."
Has this tweet been brought up yet? Cuz I we found this tweet
last night. This tweet was crazy from Hutch where somebody's
like, "Hey, why won't Camala Harris like try to actually win
our vote?"
H you I have to win your vote. Thank you.
Okay. Whoa. Whoa. >> You are a sitting representative.
>> Outcome. The best possible outcome. >> You don't
need to interrupt every time I speak. Nadine. >> Yeah,
but you're speak like >> Let me speak. I am not. >> Oh,
also by the way, I will say that if 24 hours before the election,
Hana gone, I now endorse Kamla. You should all go vote for Kamla.
If he'd done that, it still would have been like, why wasn't
it sooner? Why did you wait? You waited, you us. You waited and
you right. I I totally reject the idea that if Assan had said,
"Oh, actually all of my supporters should go vote for Kamla right
now." Right? Which I do think he'd always said, "Oh, obviously
if you're in a swing state, you should probably vote for Kamla."
Right? I'm I'm sure Hassan would have uttered that at some point
in the same way Kyle Kolinsky did. It still would have been like
you sort of like did rhetoric against her. You worked against
her. The whole thing would have happened even like you. I can
make my point in 10 seconds without
go respond. Okay. >> You seem to be
is a little longwinded of the mind that people don't have a responsibility
to use the influence they have to effect for the best possible
out outcome. You think that people get to I think that >> dude
[laughter] OGRE OGRE BOY'S IN HUTCH'S head right now. He's counting
him down. He's counting the seconds it takes Hutch to make his
point.
>> A couple seconds. You seem to think that people can
just absolve themselves of any responsibility that they have.
He's a United States representative. Okay. You cannot tell me
in one breath that Donald Trump is a fascist and then in the
next breath tell me but I'm going to stop short of endorsing
the only person that could BE HER. >> TELL ME WHAT I THINK.
>> I'M TELLING YOU WHAT you're telling me, bro. You're
saying that she didn't have any responsibility.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> You know, you shaved your head and I think maybe you
have like some sort of
>> Don't go there. Don't go there.
>> don't go. Wait, don't go. Hey, hey, leave Hutch's bald
head alone. >> Gives you like psychic powers. >> Hey,
hey, leave my friend's bald head alone right now. >> Now
hair allows you to pierce my brain
>> tell you what he thinks. >> Okay, let's go. I
think that they were using their uh their influence to the best
of the ability that they could by holding out in order to to
to get something which they knew was the only thing that would
win the election. Them kind of saying like like uh this scenario
in which they kind of bit the bullet and did some sort of like
like please vote for her like like I know like like it's a genocide
and they've like completely ignored us. They didn't listen to
us at the uh you know they they kicked us out basically at the
DNC and they are just kind of like on us by like funding a genocide
of our community. Like like like please just go ahead and vote
for her anyway. Yes, maybe in some cases that would have gotten
a few more people out to vote, but that would not have created
the sort of ground swell of support that would have occurred
if if they were >> Okay, I follow I follow you. I follow
So, so if they don't have influence sufficient to, you know,
make any kind of meaningful impact on the election, why were
they making demands? >> Well, because
that hang on, pause on that for a second. What what leverage
do they have?
>> Wait. Oh, this is um this is super easy that they don't
have they wouldn't have leverage by themselves that like the
people who were making that demand are doing it on behalf of
a community that they don't control, right? that basically that
community is making demands based on the issues they see and
the results they're seeing from the administration they'd elected
previously and that those people would withhold their votes or
or not vote based on what they're seeing and that whether or
not Hassan or whoever the else Brianna Joy Gray whether or not
they go actually you should just vote for Kamala now those people
would still have the same values they had before regardless of
the statements made to them. So while Hassan or other influencers
might not be able to command the votes, right, they are representing
and speaking with the voice of those people like saying why they
don't want to vote for Kamla, let's say, and that they can't
just command them to vote. That they they don't have that level
of influence over those people. They don't have like cult-like
dedication from those people.
You know what I'm saying? That's that's probably the the difference.
>> You're saying, well, it couldn't have really made a
difference. Then how what doesn't that annihilate the very premise?
Like it's absurd that they would be holding out for concession.
>> This is like saying basically if like if um what is
it Jesse Jackson, no Al Sharpton, let's say Al Sharpton. Okay.
Al Sharpton talks about you know race relations issues a lot.
He represents like a a voting block of black voters. A lot of
times it's like saying, you know, the black vote didn't go 100%
towards Kamla because Al Sharpton didn't endorse. And it's like,
well, you know, he says, well, even if I endorsed, it wouldn't
have changed a whole bunch of people's minds. And it's like,
"No, you have total control over black people, Al Sharpton. What
do you mean, Al Sharpton? You have total control over black people.
Why didn't you endorse?" It's like, "No, I think the the black
people while he speaks with their voice, while he's a representative
of them, he doesn't tell them what to do. He is trying to explain
to you what Hassan or somebody else was is trying to do is explain
what like people like-minded people think so that you can basically
try to make overtures to them, right?
that's
not a monolith. Well, even if they are a monolith, right, if
you're if you're working against the monolith, even if they are
a monolith, they're not going to, right? It's not about them
being a monolith or not. It's just about whether or not um they
care, whether or not they you've like won them over. Now, leaders
have like an effect, right?
If it's a 50-50 question and a leader can affect every one in
10 people, then you know that can swing the block in
but it's it's not super simple. It's not like that simple as
hutch.
act. There's also another aspect of this which is just kind of
like uh at a certain point uh people do have certain kind of
uh like principles that they like are going to like hold to and
that's under I mean is there no situation where you guys would
under like where you would respect someone who did the same if
if like I mean like >> well there are some situations no
there are some situations just they didn't present themselves
but for example
why not of all things a genocide what I'll tell If you're going
if you're going >> I'll tell you why. >> If you're
going to just last sentence, okay, if >> it's I mean the
the answer to this
while I like the way I try to communicate to somebody like Vim
is I would say something like well I understand that you don't
think Kla Harris is necessarily going to be better on this. There
probably is no worst case scenario than Donald Trump for the
people in Palestine. Like that is the worst case scenario for
their immediate safety and survival. And so voting, threatening
to withhold your vote is actually working against your interest
no matter what.
Like in this case, you are actually working against your interest
no matter what. So while I don't actually think it's a bad idea
to organize as a block and negotiate with your votes, I think
this particular case is not one that's going to actually serve
you. So I think it would be quite bad for you guys to vote as
a block against this or to not try to convince other people to
vote in Kamla's favor. Like it's it's pretty obvious that it
was never ever ever getting worse than it would be under Donald
Trump. Never get noties when you go live. Well Well, hold on.
Just go to the Twitter, turn the notifications for the Twitter
on Moody Morgan. I always announce on Twitter. We always have
a blastoff tweet, you know. Which, by the way, guys, like the
blastoff tweet, comment under the blast off tweet, interact with
the blast off tweet, retweet the blast off tweet. It helps the
stream.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
If you're going to have the cutoff at some point, then like why
why is like a genocide not the point where you start doing that?
>> I give this example a lot. Wait, let me I understand
this because Fim I give the example a lot of like I sympathize
I know people who have family in Gaza that were killed by Israel.
Okay. Like I I understand their line of reasoning of like wow
it's very hard for me to hold my nose and go say yeah the person
who helped that happen I'm going to go vote for you. But it's
our job as content creators and politicians as well, especially
so to say, "Hey, just because this thing is happening and is
awful, there are more things that are going to happen." And because
both of you acknowledge Trump is just demonstrabably worse, we
need to do everything we can to stop that. It doesn't matter.
>> Have you won the election? There's no like scenario.
>> No, wait. I I agree. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I
wait. I I agree. Wait, wait, wait. I I agree uh with your take
that the Gazi >> Pisco Pisco is going to have exactly my
take. How much you guys want to bet? Pisco is basically just
going to say exactly what I'm going to say. that Donald Trump's
the most pro-Zionist president of all time, that he is the worst
case scenario. And it's not that Biden did a good job of like
a great job of slowing BB down, but at least Biden was antagonistic
in some way. Donald Trump is straight up like, "Hey, yes, yes,
sir. Can I bomb those Iranian nuclear facilities for you, sir?"
Yes, sir. Thank you, sir. Thank you. Thank you for allowing me
to bomb those nuclear facilities for you, sir. Thank you. Thank
you. >> The issue didn't swing the election. That's why
I think it's so ridiculous sometimes for people to claim credit
that, oh, if they had, Taj's point, if they had just listened
to us, they would have won the election. I think that the loss
had to do more with prices or whatever, but that's not what people
are pointing at and why they're upset. Yeah, this response, this
quote tweet isn't directly responsive to the issue related to
whatever the seven representatives who I condemned for their
vote, including whatever Glen Kemp has, etc. Well, hold on. I
think I think a lot of these people had a good idea that Trump
would not be good domestically.
I do think they all agree. Maybe they didn't realize how bad,
but I think Pisco is about the only person who realized how bad.
Pisco is the only person
who legitimately was sitting here the whole time BEING LIKE,
"WE'RE GONNA DIE. We're all if you do this, DON'T DO IT. DON'T
do it. We're all if you do it. It's going to be full-on fascism."
And a whole bunch of even liberals were looking at Pisco like,
"You're being kind of you're being a little cringe right now.
Okay. You're a little too far right now. You're a little deranged
right now, buddy." I think Pisco is the only person I recall
like straight up being like without, you know, without being
a full-on shill, like basically trying to have a grounded argument
of why he thinks that's going to happen.
And so I think he was one of the only people who really understood
just how bad it was going to be. Yeah, you're crazy for thinking
that, MRJ. He was not he was not good in the short term. Um,
everybody would have come to a ceasefire because the the war
the campaign in Gaza was incredibly bad. optics was looking was
making, you know, public opinion outside of Israel turn against
Israel massively.
It was always going to end around the time it ended. Regardless
of who the president was,
Donald Trump will allow the rebuilding of Gaza or the whatever
happens in Gaza to favor Israelis like a thousand%. He will have
no concern at all for the the Gazins, the Palestinians retaining
their property, retaining their land, retaining anything there.
Okay? He will just say whatever Israel wants to do, you go ahead
and do it. You could say I think that nothing no pressure that
the America could have put on would have stopped the ethnic cleansing
of Gaza. I don't think you could stop that. I think there's too
much political will for that in Israel right now. But I do I
do think that Kamla might have had, you know, more to say what
like refounding or or rebuilding in Gaza. She might have had
more to say on behalf of the Palestinians. I don't think Trump
will really represent their interests at all. I don't see it.
What people are upset about isn't well we know they would have
had a statistical effect in the election. It is the priorities
of these people and what they view as the existential nature
of the threat that Trump imposes. The fact that we are all on
this plane together and we're all going to die if we don't gather
forces and do what it takes for the benefit not just of ourselves.
>> I I think this is just entirely wrong. Every piece of
reporting we have on this says Biden was furious with Netanyahu
for for lying to him, for doing like a bunch of I I think that
he was applying pressure in his way as much as he could. Now,
he's from an old guard of politics that don't just like snap
make decisions, right? He he works with like a coalition of people
within his own cabinet, within his um like his advisers in the
security not security council, the um uh whatever it's called
when you meet with all the generals and stuff. He'd worked with
a whole bunch of different people. But Biden was upset about
this and I believe he was upset about it. I don't believe he
had a good relationship with Netanyahu,
right? And I do believe he would have eventually been working
with the rest of the world to like impose sanctions and actually
curb this stuff. But
um you guys say that I there's a lot of other things going on
that you would have to consider. And if you just want somebody
who's going to be like Trump and going to totally flout norms
and totally flout like working in a coalition with the rest of
the world, then that's fine, I guess. by its but of for millions
of other people in other places including the people being slaughtered
in Gaza. And on every score of that um there's a frustration
not to be lectured to by these people. I'm not saying that it's
directly responsive to what these people are saying but you should
at least understand where it's coming from being sick of it.
It's being sick of this kind of talking down to people who wouldn't
even do the bare minimum. like beyond that
straight up like the
and maybe this doesn't pertain to the Gazin the Palestinian question
as
but 100% I do not believe that Biden or Kamla would have been
entertaining
like full-on bombing campaigns in Iran full-on bombing campaigns
anywhere else in the Middle East on like by the US I don't believe
that
>> no uh that >> I I watched the reporting unfold
I watched Blink. I watched Blinken like jet set around the entire
[__] Middle East trying to calm things down. I watched
I watched a lot of the reporting unfold. I know that he was upset.
I know Biden was upset with how Israel was approaching this >> that
that
go ahead. I ogre boy has >> there's a couple different
things here. And the first one is is essentially one of the arguments
or at least the attempt to try to make this make sense is that
it's not a matter of of what we as a group or the the people
sitting on politics nerd island. >> Okay, you guys can
say that well they would have said they didn't approve. They
would have just done this whole manufacturing consent thing.
They would have done this like um oh we really don't like this
and then we let it happen anyway. We don't do it but we don't
ever do anything. But
Trump is just about everything that that Biden would have done
and said I'm outraged or something. You could say you don't believe
it. But regardless, Donald Trump would go, "Oh, cool. Oh, awesome.
Cool. Yeah, that's fine. Yeah, that's cool. That's all good."
You know what I'm saying? Like that's that's straight up how
he would have handled it. Biden declared himself a Zionist. I
I
I think I maybe can't communicate to you guys just how bad um
Donald Trump is for Arabs in the Middle East. I'll probably never
be able to communicate it to you cuz you guys don't want to see
it cuz you guys get you get it used against you. So you guys
are like totally incentivized to never see it because you have
people like Hutch arguing that like this is the reason you lost
the election. It shouldn't be.
But I'm I'm telling you, you guys don't understand Zion Dawn
and his ways that spend all day reading. >> It's unfortunate,
but it, you know, I get it >> and listening to uh commentators
and public speakers and all this different. It was an attempt
to try to like get some kind of message across to normies and
and have normies hear what comes out of the candidates the candidate
specific mouth to say what they were willing to do. She had the
opportunity sitting across from Dana Bash to say, "What are you
going to do different?" And she said that she wasn't going to
do anything >> But played out, ogre, can I just say play
it out. So let's say, so for example, let's say that we're in
your world of political um sort of analysis. Kla Harris says,
"You know what? I'm going to announce for the first time here,
Jake, whoever's doing the debate, what's happening in Gaza is
a genocide, and I'm immediately resigning." Because that's what
she would have to do, wouldn't she? That's what she would have
to do if she were the vice president of an administration that
is a party to a genocide. In that respect, the way you're saying
is she can't be a party to it. She has to resign. How the can
she declare it as a genocide from her position as vice president
part of that administration? Talk through [laughter] it. She's
not. >> What should she have done then that she didn't
do? >> You're picking a maximum position in the other direction
to try to turn. >> So you don't hold it you don't hold
it against her. Yeah. Right. So So you don't hold it against
her. So let's play. All she had to do.
>> Can I Can we talk? What's What's happening here? Only
thing that she had to do was say yes under my >> Ogre boy
is taking the calm, cool, and collected pill. Okay.
CCNC.
Let's go. >> Hey Pisco, could you chill? Could you chill,
bro? And if evidence comes out that uh the Lehi Act or the Foreign
Assistance Act uh 620I I believe >> I will say incredibly
effective advertising for Ogre Boy over here. Very smart having
this on his virtual camera and it's like pulsating and it looks
like it's an Ogre boy stream. If you're just looking at the Streamyard,
this totally looks like an Ogre boy stream. >> That when
when and if these things are are being uh uh violated, I'll look
into it. That's it. Yeah, that would have been so
>> I'm Why would you ask me if that's what I feel is necessary
when I'm telling you what I think is necessary. >> Okay.
So, so what you have what you've just produced, right, is you're
saying I'm not asking her for the sun and moon. I just want some
sort of token gesture that she would look into her boss and everyone
that she works with for violations of the Ley Act. Okay.
And what ogre ogre ogre ogre ogre ogre ogre ogre. Let me finish.
What is the next question after she >> dude? Let me finish.
Dude, [laughter]
this is like uh uh you guys remember when Pisco like imagined
an interruption from straight raid that didn't exist? Let me
finish.
>> What you've just produced, right, is you're saying I'm
not asking her for the Sun and Moon. I just want some sort of
token gesture that she would look into her boss and everyone
that she works with for violations of the Ley Act. >> The
person Oh, no, no, no. It was It was They're both interrupting
each other. I do think I do think Pisco stepped in there very
quickly and interrupted him but then ogre boy does interrupt
back ogre ogre ogre ogre ogre ogre let me finish what is the
next question after she says you know I think that we should
look into violations of the ley act what's the next question
you produce it what's the next question go >> why hasn't
why hasn't done that
>> that's a great question >> do you feel or how
number two do you feel the ley act has been violated under administration
for five seconds
maybe our administration is violating its obligations with respect
to genocides and so if we what I actually
>> Can I go back to what I actually said as opposed to
what you tried to make me >> I said all she had to say
was essentially if if information comes across my desk that there's
violations of the Lehi Act and the Foreign Assistance Act, I'm
willing to look into it. [laughter] >> That would have
appeased a lot of the
>> So bottom line here, let me ask this because this is
this is one of the things that I wanted to get out. Do you guys
even [__] continue to read articles or stay up to
date on any news whatsoever to any of this [__]
>> Why is that? Wait, why is why is that Hang on. So first
of all, why did you just bring that up? >> Why did I just
bring that up? >> Yeah. So you're like, are you studying
your Gaza? >> Yeah. So and why is that relevant >> Because
there was an two articles that came out in November specifically
about how the Biden administration knew in 2020 December of 2023
that they were already committing war crimes in >> No,
no, no. You're getting into the substance violation of the
You're getting into the substance of the argument. That's not
what we're talking >> I heaven forbid I touch on substance.
>> No, but no, but you know that's not what we're talking
about. Do you want us to actually have a conversation about whether
or not they have violated Leyak or whether or not? Is that what
you think we're talking about, Ogre? I'm talking about [laughter]
their behalf to do what's right in order to actually >> You
don't think we're talking about the Ley Act, do you? >> Not
only to be on the right side of history, but to also simultaneously
save the potential for the election. Yes.
Let me let me jump in here. >> I'm laughing a little bit.
Sorry, I'm laughing to myself because
I just get the feeling it's like, oh no, HE'S HE'S MENTIONING
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE GROUND IN ISRAEL. NO, STOP STOP.
Let me jump in. There there's a there's a couple things I want
to point out. There have been multiple independent
>> People like Ogre Where's Where is Ogre Boy purity testing?
Where's the purity test, man?
What do you mean purity testing? He's saying I would have liked
Kamla to do this. I think he voted Kamla and like advocated for
other people to vote Kamla. Him personally,
I'm pretty sure he voted Kamla, voted blue no matter who. He's
just making the argument for the side that he represents, right?
that have done their own estimates about the projected death
toll from USA ID globally over the you can choose
don't moralize me 2025 >> no no don't moralize to me about
Gaza and imply that I don't give a [__] about like
whatever
>> what the [__] he just comes and starts yelling
at hunch awesome >> don't speak you told him to speak [__]
you The current projections
wait hot. I muted them. Start over. And then they >> The
current projections right now, and I'm gonna make I'm gonna make
my other point. The current projections now are that 200,000
kids on the low end of the estimate have died just in the last
year from US ID cuts. That number is expected to swell to over
a >> Does Hutch understand why that's like very different?
does it I maybe they'll get into this cuz there's just an obviously
different concept here where it's like USA ID that's paying for
possibly like vaccines maybe malariaetss a whole bunch of stuff
like that it's like effective altruism by the US government right
there's a lot of stuff like that and I'm not going to say that
that stuff's not good but that is taking proactive steps to help
people right
in this case the US is literally selling the arms to the country
that is doing the right in the Gaza instance It's very different
that tax dollars from the US and tax credits from the US are
being used to like further the the genocide in Gaza, if you're
calling it that. That's a there's a big difference between that.
Taking an active role in these people versus like, oh, we're
going to cut some some proactive programs that possibly we we
think, you know, more kids died of malaria or some [__]
like this. It's like they're it's very very different,
right? Your obligation
your obligation not to do harm probably comes before your obligation
to like help people overall, right? Especially to people who
already have lives and [__] Well, also nobody knew
what USA ID was before the election finished before Doge came
in and actually made cuts. Sure. Sure. Sure. >> Million.
So you have no leg to stand on. You have no leg to stand on moralizing
as though your red line of Gaza was some kind of justification
to allow the Trump administration to come in and do what he did.
I want to make my second point that I think is much broader,
which is that you guys need to stop treating these elections
like it's a game that don't have real consequences. Okay? These
are real. People are living and dying because of these things.
The outcome of the election is so enormous. >> A week ago,
>> a week ago, listening to you don't get to tell me. You
don't get to tell me. >> Dude, I like playing uh I don't
even know like Tetris over here or something. I was going to
say Candy Crush. He's like playing playing Candy Crush or something.
He's not even listening. Wow.
>> Hold on. Let me
I wasn't quite done. Stop using the threat of helping Republicans
win. You areing this whole >> Listen to me. Stop using
Republicans win.
>> I mean, does Hutch understand that like union leaders
and stuff do that too?
>> That like police unions ended up breaking for Trump,
right? Like, does he understand that it's the same? And probably
you're not even attacking one of the biggest blocks. You're probably
attacking a very small block, just one that you get more views.
There's nobody nobody cares about going after like union leaders
who are breaking towards Trump because they're getting kickbacks
now from the Trump government themselves or something like that.
Nobody would look into that, right? I don't know that that's
happening, by the way. I'm just saying that that it's very likely
to me that that's happening. That a bunch of unions broke towards
Trump. It seems quite likely to me that that would be police
unions. Maybe it could be in their interest, but for a lot of
other unions, it wouldn't be. Yeah. So, I I'm saying that people
vote in blocks. It's how they vote. You're getting mad at one
block and not the concept of block
>> This is pathetic to blame. >> Don't ask your boy
to jump in and take over for you and then jump in with his belligerent
scared >> yourself. Do I look scared, Ogre boy? Do you
intimidate me?
No, I was somebody who's banned from YouTube intimidates him.
So much so that he lies about YouTube's toos. You can absolutely
have YouTube ban creators on YouTube live shows.
>> Let me make my last point. You guys can mute that for
a second. Mute that for a second. I'm serious.
Let him respond. >> Let him respond. He cut me off, bro.
He's been screaming the whole time. It >> Yeah, because
because I'm disgusted by what you're
>> Soy. Soy pill's enjoying this. He just says Vimm cuts
into the conversation by screaming you Hutch and throwing up
like dual middle fingers at him. And [laughter] then so he feels
like Hutch Hutch, why don't you let this guy finish? Hey Hutch,
why why don't you let this guy finish? Hutch. Hutch, LET HIM
FINISH. LET HIM FINISH. >> You're saying and I need to
>> You told boy to jump in because you don't know how to
collect your thoughts and then I start speaking and you jump
in and start
exactly what I was saying. >> I'm muting all three of you.
Okay, >> Wow. I think your point was almost done, but you
did make a lot of points there and and clearly Veim wants to
have a little response to this. So, let's have Veim get a word
in then we can respond and then you can all scream at each other
again. Okay. Three, two, one, go. >> Yeah. Okay. So, it's
it's my turn now. Is that that was a >> respond. Jesus
Christ,
>> bro. You are far more to blame for this situation. So
you're you're someone who every step of the way has denied that
there is in fact a uh genocide going on to begin with. >> I
don't think that's true. I'm not like going to be like lectured
by someone who actively helped create a status quo with the situation
that that that is the reason why we lost the election because
>> I thought I thought Hutch actually looked into this
stuff and made arguments. Maybe I'm crazy. I say that I'd heard
that cuz he he like quoted some statistics he looked up once.
I that was back when I, you know, thought Hutch did a lot more
than he does. as in my defense, the the the the Dems and principally
Biden and Harris did not do not only what was a moral imperative,
but what was an imperative to get people out to vote to create
a ground swell of of like uh just like a feeling that they were
going to actively be different than than uh Biden and like like
just like you you have to start from like in order for me to
like vaguely respect anything you're saying, you have like a
and like the massive amount of of uh data that we have that points
to it actually being a genocide before you don't trip us about
this. Go ahead. >> Did you see the exit polls, Vim? Like
that that issue was nowhere near the top of why people voted.
>> Well, there I've already put in front of I've already
put in front of Hutch before like a aggregate of 34 different
polls that show that it would have meant winning in the swing
states for Kamla. And the first name on that list that put the
first poll was Locksha Jane, your guys' polling boy. Like the
information
>> the guy we had on for podcast is our polling boy. So
we
>> I Oh, so disingenuous from Pisco. Oh, Ogre boy is going
to win this. Our boy like the guy we had one time for No, the
guy you guys reference a lot. The guy you guys reference and
talk about positively a lot. Come on.
Don't pretend that you don't know who Locksha is. Don't pretend
that you don't reference Locksha all the time. >> That's
your boy. Hutch is your boy. This is your polling boy. It was
inflation and immigration.
>> Inflation and >> Pisco just dropped it. Pisco
knew to drop it. Pisco knew to just drop it immediately. He's
like, "Yeah, you know >> I'm not talking.
I'm talking about in the swing states, which she lost. Wait,
wasn't it all? It was all of them, right? Right. So, >> wait,
wait, go wait. Just just response right there. Why did you say
Oh, it was all of them, right? Are you like trying to dunk on
the fact that she lost? Like, wow. Like you're happy she lost.
That's what it seemed like. But you can tell, >> My name
isn't Jenkins. >> Wait, no. But why did you do that? Right
there. You were like all of them, right? All of them. Like you're
trying to twist a knife. >> Why are you trying to twist
a knife? I'm asking are are you are you trying are you trying
to twist a knife when you do >> Is doing some Andrew Wilson
stuff right
>> Is trying to bear down on on what do you call like nonsubstantive
issues. He's like trying to he's trying to drill down on some
stuff that isn't substantial. I've never seen him do that before.
Ogre Boy got in all these guys heads. absolute refusal to learn
any [__] lessons from this whatsoever and blindly
reflexively defend people that didn't want to win.
>> She left she absolutely explicitly left votes on the
table. And the real [__] of this is I actually brought
like a full two pages of [__] notes clips. I got
[__] that was I was going to use to make my [__]
analysis
that was going to happen. I had a conversation I I had a conversation
with Prime about this stuff and those analyses they only do like
one part of it which is like how many votes you would have gained.
But you don't do the calculation of how many votes you would
have lost. And that's what's so insane about this entire thing.
You know, any kind of you guys listen
>> uh I don't know that attacking to the right has results.
I don't think that's necessarily true. I think what you have
to do I think there's this concept that I'm starting to crystallize
in my head which is
it's actually everybody
there's there's
like a strategy for business and
that is something along the lines of just make as as many people
like moderately okay with you as possible and you'll make money.
And that strategy in general is like starting to fail. The way
you win, the way you actually build something substantial, the
way you actually build something that lasts and and is like iconic
and cool and awesome is you tell people what's cool. You tell
people what's good, right? You you basically come up with something
and you say this is the way it is and you make other people understand,
right?
I that's like
but there is something to that. And what the Dems have become
is just this like this focus grouped like nothingness.
There's there's nothing there. There's nothing. They're just
like amorphous focus grouped weirdness that they like try to
take the most popular position they can on a bunch of different
issues and it just doesn't ever work. Steve Jobs, yeah, it's
kind of Steve Jobs coded. There there are other people who do
this like culturally or in terms of, you know, products, but
you just you say this is what it's going to be and you push forward
with that. you have like a vision and there the Democratic party
is stuck being Disney and Disney sucks. I think there's one thing
everybody could agree on. Disney sucks. Every Disney product
sucks. It's all focus group. There's nothing new. It's all just
like trying to do member berries on the on the products they
bought on the sorry the the IPs they bought. Every single Disney
thing blows unless andor is probably one of these cases. I don't
think Endor was even that good. But unless they basically give
creative control to somebody and say, "Do what you want to do."
That's the only time any Disney thing has been good
is they basically give away all creative control and they say,
"Okay, go and do your
But but anytime they like try to do this focus group, all the
Marvel movies now dog. They're all dog, right?
And and that's why and that's like what the Democratic Party
is to me is it's just like focus group
or lack of a better term. Okay? That's all it is. All all of
their politicians, all of their messaging, it's all focus group.
Okay? And I can't handle it. I can't handle it. I I thought Andor
was okay. I didn't think it was that good to be honest with you.
And the sad thing is is it seems like they always get a good
idea of how to start with a with a Disney show and then they
run into the ground. We're not going to do it right now though.
>> This is actually to me this is actually really important.
>> There's an element here that you guys in Hutch specifically
which the whole point of this was like Vim and Ogre boy confront
Hutch. There's a whole cross-section of this information that
you guys never present to your audience whatsoever. there's a
half of this story that's completely missing and then maybe they
could come. >> No, this is this is [__] ogre
because you know I get a lot of because I am someone who thinks
that like we shouldn't be doing this kind of like pivot to mansion
or whatever the [__] it is. I get a lot of [__]
for for that kind of stuff. And when I say I don't think lefties
cost them, you know, Kamla the election, I'm basically saying
that by and large the left came through for Kamala. That's my
uh empirical conclusion based on the data that we have available.
What you're suggesting is the left did cost Kamla the election.
That is what you are suggesting right. >> So So I'll ask
you now. I'll ask you now. Did the left cost Kamla the
>> What? Why not? Virtue of what? >> In virt.
>> So I think he's going to say it's just on Israel Palestine,
right?
It was the loss of the normies. The ones that don't pay attention
to politics the way that we >> they cared about Kamla's
position. So the ones who are not read in on Israel Palestine,
those are the ones off of the bare minimum the bare minimum information
that they have the ability to even pull their heads up from their
lives and take a look out on a daily basis and they knew enough
to know that and then when Kamala has the opportunity to go on
a national stage and say what the she's going to do different
including Gaza was basically she's not going to separate herself
which lied about during her book tour. >> You're suggesting
that the least informed among us guys guys. She could have just
lied. Political politicians do it all the time. She could have
just lied and >> she had her people and say what and say
>> and say that she was going to implement an arms embargo
or force a ceasefire. She could what's the question?
First of all, yeah, first of all that I mean that's not going
to be People are going to be upset that she like lie or >> I
don't want her to lie, but I'm just saying to like >> imagine
she said this. Imagine she says this. I believe that there should
be an arms embargo on Israel.
>> What What do you think is the problem with the sitting
vice president coming out and saying that?
I I I don't know. But it was the right thing for her to do. >> A
it undercuts Biden in the course of the negotiations that they're
actually having where he was actually trying to push for a ceasefire
near the end. >> His vice president over there talking
genocide, talking arms embargo, talking all that stuff. These
are sensitive international conversations. Just so you're wanted
people wanted there to be a like they were getting sick as as
and and so they wanted a departure. >> Number [laughter]
two, and number I just want to finish. And number two, she looks
weak. It'll make her look weak. So I'm not saying that I don't
agree with the policy. I don't think that we should be [laughter]
I don't think we should be giving funds Israel. But but the political
but the political No, no, no. It makes her look weak. It makes
her look weak. >> Not make her look weak.
There's nothing strong about capitulating to like your your boss
like
>> um well I think Pisco said this right off the bat. ADHD
runs me was that he thinks the election was mostly just down
to prices.
Economy was doing really bad. People thought the economy was
doing really bad and that's that's what people felt and that
came through in the election. Essentially, when the economy is
not behind you as a president, you're incredibly underwater.
You need something else to run on. And Kamla basically I I don't
think this is wrong that she didn't really differentiate herself
or say they were failing in some way. They're basically saying,
"No, no, no. We we are doing a good job and we're going to continue
to do a good job." And most people if they hear that and they
don't feel you're doing a good job, they're just going to go,
"Yeah, next.
Unfortunately, even to the point of like voting for Trump, it
seems like >> just asserting yourself and doing something
different, which the the whole >> which by the way,
this probably happened to Trump as well, right? That Trump Trump
was probably in a position where he could have won that election
and then co hit and just decimated the economy. If the economy
was still going gang busters before CO hit, Trump doesn't lose
that 2020 election. Okay, I'm sorry. The campaign was not impressive
enough, wasn't even close, Trump. Trump, no, it's not about how
he handled CO. It's like if CO didn't happen, the economy would
not have been slowing down. It still would have been hot and
that election goes to Trump 100%. Not even close. >> Country
wanted her to do would have
>> Can I agree with you? and just say briefly, I agree
with you that Kamla did not do a good enough job separating herself
from Biden and showing how she would be different. I don't think
it would have mattered on the issue of Gaza. I think it had way
more to do with inflation and what she would do for this country
to make people's lives better. >> Well, hold on. To be
fair, can I can I play off that for just a moment? >> Go
for it. >> So, a first of all, no, that wasn't the singular
thing, but it would have been an indicator that she was willing
to start branching off in a different direction or a slightly
different direction from Biden. that you're you're correct in
that it wasn't the only thing, but there would have been enough
there to I think especially if it had it happened earlier that
could have gotten a lot more grassroots attention and pushed
her campaign farther than than what it had. And I still like
I said, >> WHY ARE WE EVEN CAN I ASK WHY ARE WE EVEN TALKING
about this? This is a deflection because the difference is we
are willing to acknowledge that there were mistakes. Let me finish.
We are willing to acknowledge and Harris herself is willing to
acknowledge there were mistakes in the campaign. What you guys
crucially are unable to acknowledge is that every voter who stayed
home because of Gaza did a disservice to this country and should
be ashamed of themselves. Including you, ogre, you tried to sign
and say, "Well, I told other people to vote. You did not vote
for Harris and so you have to reconcile
>> with your own shame. With your own shame, which you
have not done, you should have shame. You should have shame.
You should have shame."
>> Oh, did he do the thing where he could say he didn't
vote Kamla, but that's because he's in a super safe blue state.
Other half I was going to say to IRS point was that she lied
about knowing the importance of separating herself. After the
election, her people went on Pod Save America and said that they
knew they needed to, but they didn't know a way. She goes on
her book tour in front of the [__] you and says,
"I didn't understand that it was that important to even do it."
All of this so much of this is hope. It's insane. We We have
had so many conversations on this podcast about how Kla Harris
could have run a better campaign. I to my knowledge, liberals
do not shy away from these kinds of conversations. They happen
all the time. So that's fine. And we can we can dive into that
topic if we want to. I want to >> Why don't you dive into
the fact that she's just incredibly unpopular?
Why don't you guys just stop grabbing women that are incredibly
unpopular and trying to run them for president?
Crazy thought. I'm sorry if that's just a misogynist point. I'm
like enforcing a glass ceiling. How about you stop finding the
least likable women to run for president and then running them
and then going, "Oh my god, WE LOST." HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
Oh my god. WE OH NO. HOW DID THAT HAPPEN? I Or you know, I don't
know. Maybe maybe you think it's important. Okay. Maybe principally,
it's crazy that you can't stand principally for, you know, stopping
doing an arms embargo in Israel or stopping the genocide in Gaza.
Can't stand on that principally, but principally standing behind,
you know, voting for a woman for president, right? We have to
keep nominating women for president. I I guess that's important.
>> I think there's nothing different. I want to respond
to something specifically that Vadem said. you said or implied,
right? And tell tell me if I >> I nearly tore my hair out
when I heard this. I was just about looking like Hutch. Okay.
Hair entirely gone >> when I heard him talk about how he
thinks Harris is like the best candidate right now. Well, actually,
I think he said she was a top three candidate for him or something,
but he was talking about how she was pulling the best. And I'm
like, dude, there's no way. And then you go and look and it's
like, no, she's not close to pulling the best. It's not even
a little bit close. >> You're wrong. That Kla had a moral
imperative is the word that you used. a moral imperative to do
everything she could to get out the vote to beat Trump. Right.
You said that. You just said that. I said that she had a moral
imperative to uh I actually didn't say moral imperative in in
relation to her, but I'll No, no, I didn't. But I'll but I'll
go ahead and uh and kind of say that I I think she did. Yes.
I think that any candidate should have a moral imperative to
uh >> Okay. All right. So, she had Right. So, she had a
moral imperative, right? >> Our funding out of a [__]
genocide. >> No, no, no. I'm saying she had a moral imperative
to do everything she could to beat Donald Trump. Do you agree
with >> So, and so
and I understand that you keep going to that topic. I'm just
asking you in generalities, you know,
moral imperative that that that that performing this action would
have won her the election. I believe that and I can explain why.
>> No, I'm pass. Okay, listen. Why did she have a moral
imperative to beat Donald Trump? Specifically Donald Trump. >> I
Dude, I don't know where you're going with this. This is like
like I uh like you're you're in this moment you're kind of acting
as though >> why won't you answer my question bro? Come
on. What are you doing here? I'm just asking a simple question.
Why did she
[__] mind games and you're not you're you're not
uh accepting the simple like fact that >> Okay, let me
jump to the point. I just spare me spare me please. Please please
I just want to get I have been very patient. You guys have been
speaking. You're not but you're not you're not engaging with
me in good faith. I'm asking you good faith questions.
You're not you're not engaging with my questions. You don't want
to do it. Fine. I'll just arrive at the point. I you did say
that she had a moral imperative to do everything that she could
to to beat Donald Trump. I agree. I think the reason why she
had a moral imperative was because Donald Trump is uniquely dangerous
and him ascending to the office of the presidency was inevitably
going to lead to mass suffering. Okay. What I put to you right
now is that it's not the moral imperative does not just rest
with politicians. We are a democracy. we have a vote and people
with positions of influence like politicians or even influencers
they also >> did any of them bring up why Hutch was telling
people that he didn't need their vote and to just stay home
>> voters voters they also have a moral imperative if they
care about these issues they can see Trump for what he is to
do everything that they could to prevent that from happening
but that same you only want to talk about the moral imperative
of Ka Harris and you don't want to put any responsibility on
people that are in a democracy and have a vote and have a That's
not the point that I want to make. Shut up, bro. Stop talking
about this. Stop, >> dude. I'm wait. I got to be I got
to be both of you because this is what was going to happen. You're
talking about each other. Hutch. Your analogy of the thing of
like they're not helping build the wall, right? Hud. Please hush.
I I want you to listen to me, please. Hutch. The idea that tell
me this is wrong with being overboard. Is that [laughter] >> Oh
no. Oreo just laughed at him.
The wall right
please Hutch. I I want you to listen to me. They're saying, "Hey,
you need to build the Tell me this is wrong with Demon Ogre Boy.
I want you. The analogy of the thing of like they're not helping
build the wall, right? Wait, please. Hush. I I want you to listen
to me. Please, Hush. The idea that tell [laughter] me this is
wrong with Demon Ogre Boy is that they're saying, "Hey, you need
to build this wall out of concrete and you stack if I help you
stack up mud, it's not going to matter." And then they didn't
build it out of concrete. And then the ocean destroyed the village.
>> Wait, can I ASK OR WHATEVER? >> NO WAY. NO WAY.
OGRE BOY IS TAUNTING >> To build this wall out of concrete
and you stack, if I help you stack up mud, it's not going to
matter. And then they didn't build it out of concrete. And then
the ocean destroyed the village or whatever, right? So like,
can you engage [laughter] with like they think this is the only
thing that would have won the the election? I don't. Dude, Ogre
Boy won so hard. Oh my god.
They need to add him to the show. Add him to Live and Learn right
now. Add Ogre Boy to Live and Learn. This show goes up 500 concurrent
viewers every single week. Add him now. Add him now.
>> Agree with this, but I You're talking past both of them.
>> I I don't need you to translate for them and be like
an intermediary. Okay. He's a big boy. He's an adult. He's a
grown-up. Okay. >> You say that I was responsible, going
back to what you just said, you say that I was responsible for
Israel's genocide because Hang on. [laughter] You said that I
was partly responsible for Israel's genocide because I talked
about the issue on my stream and expressed skepticism about particular
language. You think that I am complicit in genocide? You said
directly, you said I am directly complicit in genocide, but you
don't think Rashida Talib was directly complicit in Donald Trump
winning because she refused to endorse. What is that logic? How
does that make any sense? One last time and he has made too many
points for me to effectively hit. Okay. >> Is the idea
supposed to be as long as the party? [snorts]
I MADE TWO POINTS. HOW CAN YOU NOT KEEP that in your mind? I
understand you're tired. I MADE TWO POINTS, BRO. HOW CAN YOU
NOT keep that in your mind? >> Ogre, boy, go ahead. >> Is
the idea supposed to be that if the party just waits out the
person that's wanting the concession that they can go ahead and
do? >> No, that's not the point. >> No, no, no, no,
no. That's not the point. The point is on Vadim's view. If if
the >> why why would the party ever concede? If this is
the view you want to endorse, like why would the party ever concede?
There's literally no value to the party conceding if if it's
always one side that has to say, "Well, I guess we'll hold our
nose and vote for these people again." Why would the party ever
give them what they want, right? >> Case that Hutch is
morally responsible uh for a genocide that on that same view,
right? Someone like for example Rashid Talib or for example Zoran
Mamani. By the way, I don't even grant this view. I don't even
grant this view. If that is your view, by your own logic, they're
responsible for Trump in some sense. And I even see you guys
claiming responsibility in a causal sense given that you think
that it was a but for, you know, sort of condition to her losing.
And so that's the point. The point is an inconsistent standard
that you only apply to like Hutch for the >> No, no, no.
I I need to explain what I am saying that like because I don't
really like uh I if I'm going to like really play the blame game,
I'm going to be talking about uh the the the both Biden and Kamla
did primarily. But if we are going to do some sort of hierarchy
of blame, then absolutely I am going to uh blame people like
Hutch who never took the idea that there even was a a genocide
seriously in the first place, ignored the the statements of so
many human rights uh organizations. It was the left fault then
historians. >> So it was the left's fault then, right?
That's what you're saying.
>> You more than anybody else inside that situation. But
but but the left could have prevented Trump from winning, but
they didn't because of the genocide. That's what you're saying,
right? >> No, no, no, no. What I'm saying is is that if
the the wishes of uh if uh Okay, I need to kind of like chill
to to uh to kind of
>> lick in the chat. Yeah,
>> all the way forward though. A little behind right now.
[laughter]
He's struggling. Can I just say while you gather your thoughts,
there's nothing Kamala could have said or done that would have
would have been sufficient. The goal post are on wheels. True.
It doesn't matter [laughter] what she said. It doesn't matter
what she said. She could have said it's a genocide. To hell with
Israel there. I'm going to wipe them off the map if I get in
there. It would have never ever been good enough.
Come on. >> Did you watch Biden's farewell tour? >> What
is that? Yeah. No. Yeah. Uh some of it. Why? >> One of
his final comments when he talked about the secret to his success
was saying that sometimes that you have to know like the thing
that's worth losing for. Like there's always going to be something
that it's like, well, we can't do that because we might lose.
Well, they lost anyway and still didn't do the thing that was
probably worth standing on the right side. >> We don't
grant that. We we don't grant that. What we're examining right
now is the culpability, the relative culpabilities. And by this
logic, I think you guys have to grant that Bernie Sanders is
capable for genocide because he didn't call it a genocide until
September 20.
So, so I'm just going to So, I'm just going to ask the So, I'm
just going to ask the So, I'm just going to ask the question.
So, I'm just going to ask the question. On the view that Hutch
is culpable for the genocide, Bernie Sanders is correct. No,
I I where I disagree from from Vadim, but I think his mentality
is very indicative of why we're [__] as a country.
>> Wait, Vim, do you think it's bad that ogre boy has a
genocide enabler uh poster behind >> is bad? Yeah, I mean
he's not a his refusal to use a specific piece of language to
be certain he is still farther into the correct category of of
withholding arms to Israel, speaking out about what's happening
over there and he finally got on a page that not even Hutch is
willing to get on. I think that if you are willing to use dead
palace, >> I it's I'm genuinely like in a little bit of
shock that ogre boy is doing so well on this show. Like the impression
I'm getting, which by the way, I like Pisco, so I'm normally
partial to Pisco's arguments, right? It's not like biased against
Pisco. Could be biased against Hutch, but he seems like the guy
who's trying to talk about like substantive things. And that
was just like a gotcha from Pisco, which like I get why the gotchas
are important. Like it's it's to point out inconsistency with
but is doing a very good job of just like knocking those down
and continue to talk
>> and political debate in the cynical way that you guys
do. I question if you actually give a about those people to be
honest with you. >> Yeah. I just I just think that this
is >> I don't think you actually care about >> This
is manipulation, dude. You You're the one >> I don't think
you care about them. I think you use them as pawns in political
>> Wait, let him respond. Let him respond. >> No,
no, hang on. These two constantly accused me of being complicit
in a
>> It is a disgusting smear. I spent my stream talking
about how Israel was very likely committing international war
crimes with respect to proportionality. I never co-signed the
total blanket bombing campaign that they embarked on. People
like you
never do
people like get on there and then smear me and lie and accuse
me of supporting genocide. You couldn't possibly do that if you
actually gave a [__] about this. You do not have
to. >> They are pawns in your political fight. It's virtue
signaling nonsense.
>> Support his virtue signaling. It's >> I don't
respond to that though. >> Yeah. Uh who said this? Uh Hutch,
you do not have to make absurd comparisons to DACA in order to
make the case that Palestinians in Gaza are suffering. Regardless,
if Biden was actually wanting to genocide that population, he's
currently doing a really terrible job of it. >> I was speaking
to the death count compared to the birth rate. If we're talking
about the proposition that Israel If we're talking about the
proposition that Israel was trying to exterminate Palestinians
entirely from Gaza, then they were that's gonna take a pretty
long time at the current rate was my point. >> Okay. And
it is and it is absurd to compare it to DAO. Yes. >> You
know what? This is this is actually I'm glad that we're we're
at this >> Yeah, we got to the point where you get to virtue
signal like you actually
important thing to to bring up here. Okay. So, um I you know
I came out he >> the weird the weird thing to me is like
um Matt so Hutch sometimes you bomb hospitals Hutch it's okay
I I think the weird thing to me is you can make that point but
you you also have to be aware or cognizant of the idea that like
if you set things up correctly and I pointed this out in November
of 2023. I had debates with people in November of 2023 and I
said with the with the method, not the methodology, with like
the thinking, the mindset you have of like Hamas has to be wiped
out. It's a genocidal intent. No matter what their capacity to
wage war against you is, it's a genocidal intent. It has to be
wag it has to be like obliterated, like annihilated, and we'll
do it until we'll keep bombing these people until Hamas is gone.
I'm like, you you understand you set up like the infinite machine,
right? you you can literally do whatever you want like and and
yeah, you defend, you know, bombing hospitals because there's
technically some military objective. It's like, okay, you've
set up everything here to totally destroy this place. I I would
just ask people, you know, that, right? Like there you haven't
set up a way to stop because odds are with a what do you call
like a gorilla military thing in a urban environment. Guerilla
military insurgency in a in a urban environment, you're never
going to be able to eradicate that entirely,
right?
Ever you will. Every time you kill somebody, you create like
two more soldiers. You know what I'm saying? So, you've just
created the the means by which you can annihilate that entire
population.
And people won't ever
acknowledge that
It's like yes, there is there is a world where you can strike
a hospital in military terms either intentionally or accidentally.
There is probably some world where you can do that. But the issue
is when you set up the methodology, your your your
like gut check for when it can happen and you don't set up any
like limiting principles at all. You can just justify it in infinitely
and suddenly now oh every hospital's been hit in Gaza over time.
Like every hospital in Gaza has been damaged to some extent.
Yeah. So I I think I pointed that out very early that people
just didn't had no limiting principle. There was no way you could
know when to stop. And
yeah, it's that was a correct that was a correct thing. I should
have done more debates on it. Maybe >> came here to have
this conversation. I guess I'm not monetizing this. I'm not even
streaming it. I went out of my way to do this. And I would like
you as a gesture of of uh >> I told you he was going to
do this so I told him. >> Of course I am. >> You
you watched uh Chris Consler and >> Are you doing like
a tag team thing? >> And what's that? >> Are you
doing like a tag team thing? >> I am. >> Oh no. He
thinks you're going to like Sam Cedar him. Uh I told you he was
going to do this.
>> I told you. I told you he was going to do this. I don't
know this person. >> I don't know this person. If they
want to talk on like a Discord a call or something, that's fine.
I told you he was going to do this. He's such a silly person.
Wait, wait, wait. You guys kicked me out. What the hell? >> No,
no. It looked like It looked like you just left. >> So,
of course I'm going to do this. Of course, I'm going to do this.
You watch their podcast. You straw men. You said all sorts of
>> Dude, it can't be me. It literally can't be me that
they're thinking about it. Has got to be somebody else. I'm sorry.
Just like so certain it's somebody else. >> And and in
order to continue having this conversation that we're having
right >> get to the point in like five words.
Will you or won't you have a conversation with Chris Kunsler
who you have talked about who you have straw >> I don't
remember who is this person. >> He's the uh >> you
wait on what though? >> No politic here. He's he's the
co-host of the no politic here podcast and you >> Is this
what is this what you do? Is this what you do? >> And he
asked you as do you go on debates and then say, "Oh, here's >> you
are coping." >> This is what you do. That's literally what
you're doing. Wait. What am I supposed to be afraid of? Bro,
are you proposing new [__]
What are you proposing? You're proposing a conver you're proposing
a conversation between this person and hut on Israel and whether
it's a genocide. Is that the conversation you want to propose
>> on on I would like a conversation both on what really
what whatever consular would like to to talk about. >> Why
don't you show up to debates prepared to debate? Why do you always
have to pack people in? >> Did you deflected? That's particularly
that's just really funny to me given that Vadem we watch Vadim
get like Vimm get gangbanged by what Mudahar
Mudahar and a bunch of other people on that Hutch stream right
it's just very funny that he's talking about tagging people in
when Hutch literally tag team Veim super hard on some stream
like maybe 6 months ago some guy who wrote propaganda and you
ask Ogre boy to jump in when you feel overwhelmed and now you're
doing this weird thing that I said you were going to do >> this
is so embarrassing Just you're >> Oh, Lotto Box was there
too. Everybody would jumped in for me. >> Everybody jumped
in to like Dude, they just all stabbed Vim. It's so funny.
>> Veem was also like you could tell he hadn't slept. This
one he seems like he got a little more sleep for for that one.
You could tell he hadn't slept. And he's like he keeps saying
I haven't slept. I should go. And they're like, "Oh, well, you
can go." But do you want to talk to Mudahar? [laughter] Let's
see. >> Wait, wait, wait. Convers is it the conversation
about whatever he wants to have a conversation about? I don't
understand how >> I think it would it would one be over
the uh clip that Hutch watched which he >> I'll tell you
what I will debate. I will have a [laughter] conversation with
this person. I will have a conversation with this person if you
agree to go on H3H's
>> Absolutely. Sure. But I I >> tell them tell them
to reach out to me when you do that. I'll have a >> Wait,
didn't
didn't Veem already agree to that? Did Vadem bail on H3?
I thought Vadim wanted to go on H3 and I didn't think he he bailed
on that with >> this person. >> Okay. Okay. I am
going to be working on >> Yeah, but what does that have
to do with what we're talking about? This none of this has anything
to do with what we're talking about. I thought what we're talking
about >> I don't care. Oh, no. The reason why the reason
why it has something to do with what we're talking about is because
he started making uh certain >> like and I would people
are saying H3 ran and I understand some people think that that
wouldn't happen. Some people would say no, they wouldn't but
or or no, they wouldn't have VM on because they don't think Vim's
worth talking to, but they asked Vim to come on, right?
>> Talking about things having to do with Gaza and the
genocide and whatnot that I know that Chris Hunler would be so
much more capable of handling and >> he's accused you of
not caring about it. He said, "This is just a virtue signal.
You don't really care about the lives of the Palestinians." And
I'm interested in your response to that. I mean, I don't really
think that it's like it's sort of like, you know, when Hutch
was watching JD Vance uh interviewed about he was talking about
uh >> No, I don't remember Vim making that video. I I'll
be honest, I didn't keep up on the Veim H3 stuff at all. >> Um
Hassan and the Colergate thing. Um Hutch said the most absurd
thing. One, he did not hold JD Vance in. >> What does this
have to do with I'm [laughter] lost with the Colorate stuff?
I just want Can you repeat that again? Sorry, I'm genuinely lost.
What is a collargate in JD Vance? I missed it. >> I I'm
saying that like in that situation where he was watching uh JD
Vance talk about collargate.
JDN said like the most ridiculous things about it. He said like,
you know, this is the type of thing that serial killers do. And
Hutch's reaction there was like, why didn't you address his points?
And the reason for that is is that like why why you shouldn't
is because they're just bad faith arguments. They're bull. I
I sometimes you don't want >> So you're gonna come on the
podcast and not engage in the stuff that I ask you? >> Wait,
wait. Did you say serial killers use the electro colors? >> I
probably said something. >> Dan [laughter] said that. >> Dat
Oh, Danny Van said that. Well, what does this have to do with
anything,
That was a situation in which he thought that Hassan should be
obligated to speak to a manipulative uh like tactic. And I feel
the same way here. I just like I don't feel like I have to prove
that I care about Palestine. I see. I see. Yeah. No, I would
I would prefer I would prefer us not to have the conversation
about genuineess, but um like I would rather just get to the
issue. It just does feel like >> Okay. I'm not totally
>> I'm not totally sure this should have just been Ogre.
Maybe apparently they wanted both of them on at the same time.
I do think they should have Ogre on by himself to come and maul
Hutch again. I think I think he did a great job there
to like blame Hutch substantively for genocide. Um, >> what
I'm saying is is not that he that I would never go out of my
way to blame him, but if I'm going to create some sort of hierarchy
of blame of >> I get more blame for the genocide than Rashidita
gets for >> Yes. Yes. Yes. Because of the fact that you
manufactured consent that you go you contributed to the to to
a culture that did not take it seriously.
On that on that view, you're responsible for election too, right?
I mean, on that view, you guys manufactured a consent for a situation
which you think is directly related to the reason that Kama lost
the election. The reason we're hooker boy's falling asleep. Okay.
I don't know how much more we're going to do here. This could
be good, but I haven't gotten to like the main story, which is
the fight between Asmin Gold and Hassan.
Also haven't gotten to the other stuff, the Papa Gut stuff. Papa,
we haven't got to anything else. Do we keep going with this?
Maybe do another five minutes of this. We'll see if it goes to
another place if it gets heated again. If it doesn't get heated
again, we're going to move on to the Hassan versus Asmin Gold
stuff. Okay, we're in this place. We're watching, but we're gonna
we're keep watching.
>> Wait a second. Wait a second.
>> Would you vote Would you vote for Kamala if you could
do it after one year of Trump and what you've seen?
>> Don't take it back now. You You already said you changed
your mind. >> No, no, wait. I I appreciate if you take
it back. I mean, I think that's that's good. Like, I I want to
I want to make sure that there's like a common understanding.
I mean, no, I meant like he told me that you convinced him that
he should have voted for Kla and now he's like hesitating cuz
he's afraid of getting like [laughter] I don't know what it is.
>> Wait, hold on. Say that again cuz you got cut off. >> Now
that you've seen one year of Trump, now that you've seen one
year of Trump, >> shut up. Hutch specifically. What the
[__] did you just say? >> You told me that
Pisco convinced you that you should have voted for Kamla and
then I asked you should should you have voted for Kamla or do
you wish you would have? And now you're like hesitating. >> No,
I said yes after one year. Sure. Yeah. No. [laughter] Why the
[__] You know, he says because I think he says it
because like we're all all of us are like attacking them. So
I I mean I understand. I just think >> this is like there's
so many gotchas happening all over the place here. It's literally
no substantial conversation. It's literally just didn't you say
this? Do do you take this back? Are you are you willing to stand
by this? It's like okay. I mean at some point you should have
some actual conversation. >> I think you just own it ogre
boy. And I think that's fine to do. >> But that's not the
argument. That's not the argument. >> What do you mean?
There's this over overwhelming uh urge to try to put it off on
anybody but the candidate that everybody else
has. The whole point is oh my god mute the [__] out
of me into oblivion or I'm going to finish my way finish. Sorry
>> this constant thing and especially this was one of the
like I don't have a big interest believe it or not and everybody
across the internet and lip circles is about to scoff. I don't
have some big desire to necessarily defend Hassan when it comes
to the specific argument that you soy
>> tried to make a couple of week >> I felt it I
felt it was incumbent on me to scoff there >> ago this
notion that like he should be doing everything in his power to
get her elected when my argument is and on another night maybe
with somebody else I can maybe have this conversation is that
she didn't do any everything in her power to get elected. That
is always going to be my point and the thing I want to see is
a Democrat that's actually going to try to do everything in their
power to get elected. Ogre boy, I'm the most on your side of
being able to steal man your argument that you think that if
she had done this, she would have got more votes. But Hassan
is completely aware. He's a big boy and can say, "Hey, she's
not going to change. It's two days before the election. I should
tell millions of people to go
>> at that point. What could do the vote for? What do you
mean?" >> After that much time, Hold on. No, no, no, no.
after that. >> Now, Ogre Boy is going to make a good point
here because I just made this point that after you've after you've
educated people on the issue, after you've spent a whole bunch
of time talking about the issue, right?
I feel like it might be difficult to go back and just say like
it would do something, but would it do anywhere near as much
as you think? No, I don't think watching the candidate after
that much time of watching the candidate not respond to things
that everybody else can see with their eyes if they're being
good faith then suddenly they're just going to go it let's do
it anyway after that they've been ignored on so many different
options >> that that's not okay you understand
to Hassan not telling his people to go vote >> like Pisco
is going to make the argument and you could make this argument
in the other direction that it was bad for him to ever start
criticizing given the outcomes of the the the risks of the election
right that's the other argument
would not have done anything then I guess but I don't even know
what we're doing in terms of politics, right? Why even bother
here? He said that Trump was going to be worse. He educated his
audience about the the effects of the Abraham Accords. He pointed
out what was in 2025 in regards
enough. I can't even. He did more to educate about the dangers
of Trump than your [__] ass, dude. >> You're
[clears throat] bald, though. Take your hat off. Take your hat
off. Take your hat off. Take his hat. Tell him to take his hat
off or he gets kicked off, [laughter]
>> dude. Uh, Hutch just got so
[laughter] no. Come on. Take it out. Take it off. >> Don't
Don't take your hat off, Ogre boy. Never let him take Never let
Hutch dictate terms to you. Okay. >> I think you have to
take the hat off. >> Take the hat off. No, I'm good. >> I
don't hate your Let's not do this. Let's go. Let's put the Listen
Listen. I I think that the question is like, is there blame for
the candidate? Absolutely. Everyone has their pet critique of
Kamla. We've had it. We've had entire conversations about it.
Is there blame for people who did not support the candidate?
There has to be, right? Of course there is. Of course there is.
How can there not be? And we just want to see a consistent approach.
And so I don't think that the left cost commonly election. That's
my view based on the data. I don't think that I I'm not convinced
that it was this withholding the vote. I think it has to do with
what IR said. It's people perception of Biden's age. It's the
prices. It's the economy stupid. It's that kind of all right.
That's my view. But the anger comes when certain people try to
like moralize and talk down who never ever signal that they were
going to vote for uh Kamla or said that they ought to vote for
Kamla. That gets people upset. >> I think it comes down
to there. >> I think it comes down to you're vote shaming.
That's >> Hold on. Let's be fine. Wait.
Yeah. Yeah. Hutch. Hutch knows Ogre boy is bald. Vote vote shaming.
If you voted for Trump like we would vote shame, right? Uh yeah,
but >> big kick finally fixed botting Aiden Ross at 10K
live viewers right now.
>> Yeah, possibly. >> In a situation in which people
are act
just countermoged ogre. Wait, what did he say? Maybe I missed
it cuz somebody said I agree with Hutch on that one and I don't
even know what that is.
What? What did he say?
>> Doing something
again. If they had actually responded in this way, she would
have >> Hutch said kick him if he doesn't take his hat
off and then he kept his hat on and he stayed >> won. And
I can explain why I think that it's not because of the fact that
I think that like that uh issue alone necessarily would have
like uh enthused everybody to go to the polls, but it's like
like I said before, they wanted to see some like huge
assertion of her individuality to separate herself from Biden.
And doing something that like that one would have like created
a lot more like
you would have had you would would have had lots of people who
are who are influencers who would be like genuinely excited rather
than like saying like oh you know like I know things suck right
now and what does it matter what does it matter if
please instead of >> oh do we have a Larry Ellison >> hold
on Veim doing a Larry Ellison right >> does it matter Pretty
please. Pretty please. Oh, pretty please. Instead of of that,
they need to use that tone. You don't need to you don't need
to go pretty please.
>> Oh, tourniquet. You understand? Literally everybody
knows that boy is bald, right? Literally everybody knows this.
So, it's not like he was actually hiding the baldness. He was
just saying, "No, I'm not doing what you ask."
Literally, everyone knows that.
>> You can very simply just
accurately. No, no, no. I've never asked for that. All I ask
is that people tell the truth, Vim. Just tell the truth. >> Okay,
I'm
let me uh let me duplicate this. I want to I want to move forward
a little bit cuz I'm hearing >> answer for me and I'm >> big
things happening over here as well. >> But I I think that
if uh
>> you're you're trying to twist the knife. >> It
could possibly create skepticism. That's fine. But surely you
would agree that sometimes you can have overlapping interests
between people that you align with and maybe some right wingers,
right? Like for example like how do you feel broadly about the
um KO Institute? Um, most of the time I I if I'm getting uh you
know what I'm I'd have I know that I've heard the name.
>> Oh, you don't like the Institute. You hate the KO Institute.
>> They're like a right-wing libertarian think tank, but
they're also like >> Yeah, they're probably bad news. >> Okay.
But they're also like super pro-immigration, right? So that's
overlap with like the leftist position that we should be massively
increasing our immigration. So it's fine to be skeptical, but
you seem to be closing yourself off to the possibility that sometimes
good policy that has good outcomes could overlap with like, you
know, people that you find to be uh unsavory, right? said the
wall was a good idea. So, you know, we we do need to be open
to Why are you doing this? See, like said the wall was a good
idea. So, you know, we we do need to be open to Why are you doing
this? See,
>> oh, Ogre Boy went with the gotcha and Pesco is very
mad about Ogre Boy's got. >> The thing is, it's not just
that um you disagree in terms of comm's position. It's that you're
so smug about it, Ogre. Like, you're basically suggesting Yes.
No. Yes, he is. In that moment, what is he doing there? He's
you're trying to twist a knife and you're trying to be like,
"Haha, come lost. What a [__] joke." Like does it
doesn't sound like someone who's turning a new leaf and realized
how horrible things are and they should have voted. It sounds
like you're trying to twist the knife. >> It's a silly
point too, by the way, >> Wait, he's not twist
twisting the knife. He thinks he's correct. He's like, you guys
ran a candidate and you got a you got the result you didn't want.
Eat.
It's not like he's happy Trump's president. He's saying, "Hey,
maybe you need to learn something." Democrats have never opposed
like any structures or fencing. That's been the standard Democratic
position for decades. Donald Trump's proposed border wall was
a border wall that stretched along the entire southern border,
which is like 2,000 miles and completely unworkable in many locations
because there mountain ranges. There's eminent domain issues
with people's property. But the Democrats have never opposed
like any kind of structure. And what was in that bipartisan border
bill was funding that was appropriated by the Congress in 2019.
And it was just asurances that that money would be spent on border
wall. And it was it was pushed out to >> watched you watch
this video this week. You went out of your way before she ever
got to the statement to try to defend it reflexively. The optic.
>> Are you gonna respond to what I just >> Are you
gonna respond to what I just said? Are you just saying you do
that all the time? >> Not. But you're not responding to
what I just said. Like the idea that Kla Harris has supported
Donald Trump's border wall is not true. It is false. >> She
said that. No, I think there's a way you could phrase a critique
which I would accept. I just want to give over what he wants.
There are ways in which you can phrase a critique which I would
accept which are Democrats have been much too accepting of the
the framing and rhetoric on immigration. That's even something
Asana has said which I agree with. But how you say it, I think
you're this is the kind of thing that sometimes you guys do.
How you phrase it is so annoying. Like yeah, you can just say
they should have voted for like act [laughter] shouldn't have
made this policy position. That's all well is good. But >> Anderson
Cooper specifically said that >> ogre boy. Hey Ogre boy,
could you just be nicer? Hey Ogre boy, could you just be nicer?
>> Talking against this wall for the last [laughter] eight
years, calling it a narcissistic monument to a bigoted. >> He
was wrong to frame it that way. >> And she in turn said,
"I'm not going to turn down a good idea regardless of who it
comes from." She was specifically talking about the wall. That
was a moment that was >> obviously she was obviously
older boys got a quote. Uh oh. Was that wrong to frame it that
way? >> And she in turn said I
>> Anderson Cooper specifically said that you've been talking
against this wall for the last eight years calling it a narcissistic
monument to a bigoted. >> Yeah. He was wrong to frame it
that way. >> And she in turn said I'm not going to turn
down a good idea regardless of who it comes from. She was specifically
talking about the wall. That was a moment that >> obviously
she was obviously responding. >> That was a moment. That
was a moment in time when a lot of people that she was trying
to appeal to by going on tour with Liz Cheney that she was trying
to appeal to that they looked at what she was saying and saying
this she doesn't mean anything. She's not being serious. There's
no convictions. >> Come on. Are we going back to the >> purchased
she lost a lot of the purchasing power that she had in trying
>> I mean the I don't know if she lost a lot more. I think
that's a good example. I don't know if she lost a lot more than
already going on tour with Liz Cheney. And I think a lot of people
try to defend that and say oh that did m No, it did matter. It
does matter. That's somebody you that your party's painted as
evil for like years and years and years. Every medial lined establishment
that's with you has painted her as evil for years and years and
years. And you're like, "Yeah, we're going to join with evil
to defeat evil." And it just muddies the water.
Like obviously it muddies the water. It was it was
>> trying to appeal to those moderates
Liz Cheney too. Everybody hates Liz Cheney. Everybody hated Cheney.
Literally nobody was sad when Cheney
And I I almost never ever
comment negatively about somebody when they die. I'm like whatever.
People can have their time to grieve. They had family. Everybody's
human. But maybe not Dick Cheney. This is the one guy.
>> Independence in the >> when I But when I asked
you and I and I hope you have a better answer for me and I I
would actually you know what Vidim, let me ask you a question.
And it's not a gotcha. I just want to know. Let's say >> I
don't believe you.
>> Can I just say can I can I just can I just say I agree
with there. I don't believe you either, Hud.
>> The January 6, the the the team up with Liz Cheney was
over January 6th.
I want to confer with my tag team partner here for just a moment.
What he's about to ask you is is how do you dig yourself out
of a hole that you yourself created in the first place by putting
a major issue on the back burner. Take it away, Hutch. >> No,
no, no. Okay. What I'm asking you is when AOC, let's say she
runs, when AOC is on the debate stage and she's up against her
Democratic primary opponents and uh the moderator asks her and
they're going to ask her this question. They're going to >> Hutch.
Hutch has an alt account that he's logged into on his phone on
Twitter and it's only got Ogre boy notifications on. Okay. Whenever
Ogre boy tweets, if you turn your notifications on for Ogre Boy,
okay, on Twitter, whenever he tweets, you'll notice Hutch's phone
like vibrate and he'll look down at his phone 100%. Okay, he's
got them blocked on his main account, but there's some burner
account he's got where he does follow Ogre Boy and he gets all
of those notifications. Okay, >> say ogre boy is in Hutch's
mind 24/7. >> The border got really chaotic under Biden.
The public largely turned on the Biden administration. It was
a number two issue. People were very concerned about border security.
Many people voted for Donald Trump because they wanted more border
security. Um do you think that Biden handled that well? And if
not, what would you do differently? What would be your policy
that you would implement if 800,000 people per month start showing
up at the border? >> Um honestly, I think that that's like
a little out of my depth. I'd have to kind of do some research
to uh kind of uh like really >> No, no, but I will I will
say one thing quickly which is just that I believe that we need
to continue to like I'm not sure if this is would have been the
right thing for him to say in the >> Ogre boy is not the
guy who quit the living pod. No, >> but I support creating
more ads to
>> Connor boy is who you're thinking of. That was that
would be a Connor boy. >> Wait, would you grant that? That
was that was position, right? And and I also think that they
actively needed to
uh in in a very very substantial way to speak to to speak against
the propaganda that they were really like fading fat
>> so out of line this whole time and I'm going to throw
a jab at him and you're going to clutch your pearls. >> No,
it's certain limits. Three hours is is is a lot for me and I'm
just not able >> is a lot for you. >> Vadem is sleepy.
Veim. And now he's gotten tired. Okay. >> Hey. Hey. No.
Hang on. One second. One second. [__] him. [__]
him. Wait. So out of line this whole time and I'm going to throw
a jab at him and you're going to clutch your pearls. >> No.
You've been belligerent against me the whole time, bro. >> That's
fair. That's fair. You You can do that. Like I I grant you that.
But I will say that like I mean I I don't think you like like
just maybe a after we we talk uh you know this is over talk with
Soy Bill about like my medical issues. They're not It's not like
It is not at all. >> Is being a [__] prick
like one of the side effects of your >> No, but that's
not what he's talking >> I mean probably.
I mean to be real I do think being a prick would be a side effect
of not getting any sleep. I think Hutch brings it out of him.
But yeah, I would expect Don't you aren't you cranky after you
don't get any sleep? Man is him. >> What he's talking about
has to do with his stamina for doing it. Not about him being
a prick earlier. I mean that's difference. It it's it's really
it's it's very much about that. Um I'm okay with sticking around
for maybe like another 10- 15 minutes. I do have one point that
I want to make which is outside of all this which I don't think
is going to provoke a very long conversation. So at some point
I want the ability to say that
but I would Okay, we could Ogre Boy. Let's do the last point.
>> Are you sure? I'd like to open it up to Okay, that that's
fine if if that's how Ogre Boy feels or to cents on all this,
which will undeniably be a whole >> bunch of but um I wanted
to specifically to speak to uh you you asked me to um reach out
to Ethan Klein. I will in the future when I like I'm I'm working
on a video that's probably going to be a little while before
it's up. I want to make sure that you know that. The other thing
that is even more important that I wanted to uh convey here is
that um just so you know I there is this like uh
I I don't think Vim's a bad person. Okay. But like I wish
every single public speaker wishes they had onetenth the confidence
of Veem
like to just keep talking in any given situation.
I feel like most people when they're speaking in front of like
big audiences and stuff, they get like nervous that they're wasting
people's times or wasting people's time. And Vim has never thought
that once. Veim is just like he is you are here. You're his audience.
You're captive. Okay. I'm just like, bro, I wish I had any of
that confidence. Sometimes I'm like, maybe I'm not making my
points well enough. Vim is just like, I'm going to I'm just saying
all of the things that come into my head and that's the way I
operate. And so, I had one more thing I wanted to talk about.
And what I really wanted to ask you guys is something that's
important to me. It's near and dear to my heart and I don't know
what your guys' opinion on it is going to be. I suspect it's
going to be something like this and you know Ogre Boy had some
thoughts on it. We talked about it beforehand and I've seen IRI
comment on it before and Pisco I'm not really sure what your
opinion would be but I think you guys are going to say something
along the lines of a thing which I've heard from other people
in the SP. It's like, "BRO, BRO, BRO,
just say something. Just say anything. Jesus Christ, please.
For the love of >> I dodged Ethan." Uh, and and I don't
know if that is kind of like where you were coming from with
asking me to talk with him. Like, basically on the show, he presented
it like I was dodging him. He uh refused to like he cropped out
our messages in order. >> Yeah. There are just times of
the day where it's very funny. >> I was ducking him and
I absolutely was not. So, I just want you to know that when you
are discussing it so that you're not basically like spreading
some BS like this guy is calling me a but he wouldn't talk to
to Ethan. That's not the case. So, >> tell Ethan to stop
dodging me. Hutch. Tell Ethan to stop dodging me. That's most
more important. >> Well, I don't know the Why didn't you
go on the show if he invited you? >> Um, he invited me.
told me that I could come on any time that I wanted and I uh
made the
um thinking about it just remembering that the details I made
the uh the date with them and then something came up on my end
I wrote them and said that I couldn't make it and then literally
one minute after that like one minute after that I wrote like
but I want to reschedule as soon as possible give me a list of
dates like like something like that um it's on like Donkey Kong
and they cropped it right at the point like literally you can
see if you look at the full picture because it's like Twitter
and you can see the like timestamps. You can see that one minute
after the first message that that I sent came the other and >> dude
Pisco Pisco should just say get him on get Pisco on >> and
they uh like showed it like >> your was and then on top
of that Ethan couldn't even make it himself. They didn't end
up doing a show that day. So it's just kind of ridiculous in
all sorts of ways. I was not ducking him. If anything, it's the
other way around. I made it very clear. I also messaged Dan,
you know, the like like one of the uh the the crew guys and just
kept on saying like, "Have me on, have me on." So, that is the
actual story with that. Just so everyone knows >> that
was the thing that you wanted to >> Oh, I do wonder if
they got rid of a little bit of botting or something. I just
noticed he's a view count. I do wonder if they're >> close
on. >> Yeah, I wanted to make sure that you knew that.
I mean, I guess I could uh say more substantially that it's my
belief with all of the uh you know, vote discussion that that
we had that um you know that I I think that by
shaming those who took a principled stand inside that situation,
it's my belief that you guys are actually creating more voter
apathy by creating this, you know, contributing to this feel
of it being kind of like we're, you know, it's it's our you're
in. You guys are out. And um I wouldn't feel that way. I wouldn't
feel that way if I didn't think that those people were actually
doing something active to create a necessary change that they
felt like they had to do. Again, like I don't think that they
worked against the endeavor to for for >> this is 2.5.
I think that they did actively did something to to to like help
the situation. And and uh that's that's
I don't even shame necessarily Trump supporters in general. I
obviously think they deserve it, but like a lot of the times
you can embrace these people with empathy and like have them
admit they made a mistake. The problem is when these people who
chose to do what you say, take a stand, then come out and talk
about the Democrats like, "Wow, look how awful this is and this
should have happened." It's like, "Well, what did you do?" And
the answer is, in my opinion, not enough. So, it's it's not people
that everyone voting. It's specifically the talkers. >> I
mean, yeah, but I I go on the Vanguard, I go I I go talk to lefty
people. I go on Crystal and Kyle. I interface with these people
in good faith. And I don't at every opportunity say, "You know
what, Crystal Ball, you really should have endorsed Conair."
I don't do that. >> By the way, what was Veem's point there?
I actually don't recall. Veim had like one point he wanted to
make and I actually don't know what the point was that he wanted
to make.
I'm not I'm not actually not joking. What was the point?
I actually don't know. >> But it's when people come with
this attitude and start talking, you know, that's and >> his
point Oh, maybe his point was that he didn't dodge H3. Yeah,
that was his point. That was his point. It was that it was that
he didn't dodge H3. >> Call that out. You know,
you're right. I respect that. I respect that. But that's like
why I'm here talking about this in the first place. Guys, guys,
guys, nice guys. Hutch is trying to talk. Hutch is trying to
talk. [laughter]
>> I can't believe how hard Ogre Boy just owned Hutch this
entire episode. It's so [laughter] fun. >> Take initiative
on that one. Um I I don't dispute that people like Hassan and
people that are kind of in the circles that you guys prefer uh
that have good intentions. Like I don't dispute that they want
good outcomes for people. I don't think they're evil people in
service of some kind of evil agenda. I just >> both like
we're using dead Palestine as an ornament. >> I find your
tactics I I firmly believe that I find your tactics the [__]
I find your tactics to be completely incoherent. I I don't know
what principle you're upholding by taking some kind of action
to materially assist Republicans winning elections. I don't think
that gets you anywhere closer to your goal. And kind of expanding
on that a little bit, I don't think it positions you guys to
actually extract more concessions in the future because if the
party apparatus views your particular wing of like leftwing politics
or supposedly the Democratic Party coalition, if they view you
guys to be unreliable members of the coalition, I don't know
why they would prioritize trying to hurry favor with you guys
over pivoting to the center. I'm saying that you can push politicians
when they're in office and I think Biden is a really good example
of this. Like he was pushed left on a number of >> this
is this is just wrong. I like I my only issue with what lefties
did was that I don't think it served their interest.
I think you have every right to withhold your vote. That is a
part of your power of having a vote. I think you have every right
to organize into blocks to withhold your vote or to like cast
your vote in a direction of somebody trying to get it. I think
you have every right to do that. And I do think that the the
willingness to enforce that is the only thing that gives you
power in the first place. If you will never ever enforce it,
no matter how bad they like lie to you or with you, which I'm
not saying it's that bad, but if you will never enforce it, then
you have no pressure. You have no leverage. You have nothing.
You have no power. >> Open you had an open door with Biden.
You had an open door. Not everything. Not on Gaza perhaps, not
everything. But now where are the protests against the Trump
administration? >> Is that that way? >> After after
he won, he invited the leftwing to be in the discussions about
what should go in the ARP. And no, they didn't get every provision.
Yes. You know, people like Mansion and Cinema blocked some provisions
on >> his domestic policy was his domestic policy was influenced
a lot by >> Bernie and and Warren and like a lot of the
activist groups. You know, you can you have that opportunity
to get those concessions after they win. If you guys continue
to do this strategy of we're going to threaten to help Republic
>> Joe Biden was probably in terms of Democrats the most
populist economically the most populist president economically
that they've
maybe ever I I can't say ever had because I don't know, you know,
older US history. I don't know like ' 70s and pre-70s US history
very well. But in a long time, in my lifetime at least, right,
I he's easily the most populist economically that's existed.
So I do think if you like economic
he absolutely was. Like that's not even really in question. >> Republicans
win. I don't know what choice you give the Republican party.
>> No. Is that really a lot of economic populism? No. But
it's something. It was something, right? >> This is the
victory. This is the victory of the Bernie side of the the the
victory of the Bernie wing um in 2016 and 2020 manifested itself.
>> Well, yeah. Sorry. I'm not I I realized I was like,
"Oh, I don't know." Like FDR was definitely more, but he was
in terms of populist economics. Maybe since Clinton, wait, in
what universe is Clinton a engaging in populist economics?
What part of NAFTA was populist, bro? >> In saying Biden's
administration domestically, and you don't want to take credit
for it, even though it was the most leftwing domestic policy
we've seen in decades, perhaps ever. And so [laughter] that's
what I don't understand. Like Bernie did something incredible
to the Democratic party. attorney incredible by hanging on to
the last minute in order to get as much concessions as humanly
possible. >> No way no he endorsed Hillary Clinton. He
endorsed he endorsed both Hillary. He endorsed uh Joe Biden and
it's a great >> I think that guy I either misunderstood
he's maybe since Clinton. >> You mean before Clinton the
progressively blamed Bernie for staying into the races for as
long as he did?
No. Well, we can debate that but I think he 2016 I do. I do think
it cost that. Yeah. But he took a different approach in 2020.
Do you realize that? As soon as as soon as it became obvious
that he did not have a path, he dropped out very immediately
after Super Tuesday and endorsed Biden. That was the correct
thing too. >> It wasn't immediately after Super Tuesday,
but it was obvious once No, it was it was around the time that
I believe Wisconsin, if nothing else. There were several. >> You
might be right. I say right after more primar and ultimately
he did drop out, but it was after the the idea of the risk associated
with making people stand in lines during COVID and the sort of
health toll that that was going to take on people. >> Well,
either which way that was the correct move to do and he got a
lot of criticism from the left flank for um endorsing Biden.
A lot of people viewed that to be a betrayal. But I think that
that itself kind of shows you that people that have that kind
of view, I I really don't think that they're seriously gaming
out the dynamics. And I think it's misguided. I don't think they're
evil. I don't think Assan is evil e. I don't think you guys are
evil. But philosophically, I don't think I don't understand the
principle that you uphold by allowing Donald Trump to win or
by not doing everything he can. >> Do you actually think
in your heart of hearts that the [__] that Madani
did by listening to people a year out asking what is it your
main concern about living in this city and then making his campaign
pillars exactly that? Do you actually think that that's leftist
or lefty? I think that's just No, I think that's just But you
look again,
>> I'm trying I'm trying to simultaneously agree with you,
but make something that's a very important point. >> You
have said time and time in the past that that wouldn't work in
other cities in other states because it's too blue, it's too
lefty. It's not something you can do anywhere else. Yes, you
have. You sure as [__] have. >> No. No. >> And
the idea also, one of the other things that Oh, sure. [__]
it. If you want to disagree with that, that's fine. But you certainly
>> I So, I think Hutch is probably quibbling on the idea
that listening to the people and doing what they want wouldn't
work. He's probably saying like free buses, free grocery stores
or whatever or or you know, city- owned grocery stores wouldn't
work in other places. That's probably what Hutch is trying to
say is what he meant. >> No, I said people should adopt
Mum Donny's approach and take whatever. Yes, of course. In any
in any kind of race, I think the same. That's what I was saying.
You can't copypaste his policy prescription necessarily, but
you should definitely look to him for lessons in terms of interfacing
tonight is anything good comes from tonight that that we can
shake hands on is you turning around and saying that people should
adopt Mandani's approach nationwide. Yeah.
What do you think? >> What do you think of mom Donnie endorsing
hok you [laughter] >> probably a little >> both of
you
All right.
CPan has a woken >> answer that I probably out of here
after this. I don't give a [__] about this conversation.
What do you think about
>> I am undecided. I think that the
I think that the arguments that I've heard on both sides are
compelling to me and I've only pretending that they're going
to go a long do they go longer than 3 hours? I feel like 3 hours
is the maximum I've ever seen the show go. Why is he pretending
that? Oh, get them out of here. We I don't want to have this
convers They've been on three hours, >> I'd want to engage
with it more before I said any more than that. What about you?
>> What kind of answer is that? No, I said it was probably
>> an honest answer. >> So, I I have a response to
that because I was incredibly insensed at Hokll when she decided
not to initiate any kind of action against Adams in response
to like one of the most corrupt DOJ actions that we've ever seen.
However, even though I was insensit I said I will never abide
by any support of like Hok I won't do it. Um I am not going to
in this moment say mom Donnie is I'm gonna throw him in the trash
because he decided to endorse Hok because there's a pragmatism
about me which is if I want Donnie to achieve his goals. If I
want to achieve his goals then I understand that there's a there's
a window of space intolerance that I'm going to grant there.
And so I have no problem and I think that that should be the
attitude is that we're harm reductionists and if you want mine
to succeed he needs to have the support of Albany. And so I don't
understand why why it's the case that this becomes an issue.
It's like a lot of lefties not necessarily you guys are immune
to power and immune to what it takes. That's one of the things
I think I know you said not you guys, but by and large you're
not the other people that you're arguing with at the moment.
But you're hurting what you just said. He endorsed her too soon.
So that's that is who he's hurting mom by not getting behind
him and not finding a reason to support his decisions. Even Mandani
is not good enough. Why? Why is it that blind support for for
public support? >> No one's talking blind support. No,
no one's talking blind. >> So why are you assuming I don't
support
>> How is that? Okay, I have an I have an opinion that
it was probably a little too soon. much in the same way that
this is the problem that the Democrats should have that the Democrats
should have waited maybe another week before they gave in and
uh
[laughter] >> this is hereby there's no consistency and
no through line >> I hereby declare Madi belongs to the
liberals now he's ours okay cuz you guys will you guys will turn
on him fully at some point I promise you I promise you a certain
a certain Turkish American streamer who I will not name uh was
today
like turning on politician >> a certain Turkish Turkish
American uh streamer who I will not name said today that uh Mandani
cannot yet be considered a betrayer. That's what he said. So,
I also said
I just like I get where Hutch is coming from. It's just the
It does seem like a lot of people are just like, "Okay, we um
the only solution to manga is blue manga like over and over again."
And it's like, dude, I I think that's like better in the
in the like extremely short term. And then you're going to find
out exactly why that approached over the the Republican party
too. >> Part of the regime which was that day is coming
where they fully abandoned him. And I I I have been so impressed
with mommy this whole time. The problem with the Hok race is
that the primary challenger the primary challenger is 50 points
behind Hok. Hok is plus 15 in the state of New York. Okay. She
has the leverage in this spot. He needs her more than she needs
him. That's the reality. But I feel like you guys just want to
fight every single fight. And you call it principal. What the
[__] are you doing? I didn't [laughter]
They are. They are. Like Ogre boy said, "Oh, maybe a little too
soon, but I'm fine with it." And then Vim said, "I don't even
know who the [__] that is. I don't even know what's
going on, dog." And Hutch is like, "YOU PEOPLE ARE the worst."
Like, wait, what? [laughter] You understand? You're signaling
something that's not us, right? Come on, man.
[laughter] Let's give Medboy the final word, guys. Uh, give your
thoughts on the whole conversation. Tell us where people can
find you. What's coming up for you? Vee, you go first. Uh, I
am uh >> I I hope if if Ogre Boy says that he's just going
to be like snarking Hutch's stream for the rest of time, I
I'll literally gift him subs right now. >> If that's what
he says, if that's his
>> find me on twitch.tv/ogboy6
time way too long
weeks. And uh I I think you'll hear about it whether or not you
go and subscribe if uh you I mean I'd really like just to say
that um um you know >> yeah possibly I didn't finish reading
righteous mind but you might be right sting slot that it is incompatible
with with with um Democrats that this level of sort of like slavish
deferral is incompatible with a liberal mindset or a left-leaning
mindset. You might be right >> having me on um and uh really
I don't
anything to uh kind of wrap this up. I I feel like my brain is
evaporating in real time right now, but I would like to maybe
Ogre doesn't want to take the the opportunity, but I I would
like to say
>> uh my socials are at the bottom of the screen. Uh basically,
tonight I really overprepared. Obviously, I have pages of notes
and links and clips and articles and all of that proved to be
nothing. I wanted to have a substantive conversation about the
responsibilities of the candidate versus >> invite him
back. >> Voting especially normies. We did this and it
was what it was. invite him back. >> Also, I have to pick
like a racehorse. So, just glad that this is coming to a screeching
end. >> All right. Well, thanks for coming on, guys. I
think what I'll do is I'll remove you two and then uh you guys
can also then everyone else can plug their stuff. Thanks for
coming on. Uh see you guys later. Appreciate you. Yep. Peace
out. Bye.